okay so we are officially live uh this
morning with tom ellsworth adam we got a
lot of things going on
good morning we made today try some
tequila yes we may so we talked about
we're good last time we talked about you
know we may try to
and we got uh the two different kinds
that he has sam text yesterday which one
should we get so let's taste both of
them we got the shot glasses here
and uh we we we may try it and see what
happens what we do know is uh adam why
don't you tell everybody how many
glasses of coffee you've had this
morning i've had about uh
this this will be my sixth potentially
liquid consumption i've had five cups of
coffee five cups of coffee this morning
so you're ready you're on fire i don't
know why i usually get i'm a seven hour
eight hour sleep guy i had four last
night i needed a double double you're
seven or eight seven or eight i put you
like eight to ten i'll take eight to ten
on the weekend i could go 12.
really if i if uh if i'm if i'm out
drinking teremona tequila the night
before i don't know if i've ever slept
12 hours what do you think i am it's a
beautiful feeling seriously i don't
think the biz dog sleeps i think you're
just doing case studies in your
cigarettes no
first of all i've seen this like many
times i've seen biz doc sleep in
meetings yeah
in his own strategic
[Laughter]
we were at your house smoking cigars
this was what two three weeks ago when
all the guys were here
rodolfo and jose and shout out to all
those guys and obviously zapala
and biz doc is is nodding off he's on
the couch
and it's probably midnight
and the guy's out i think he's out so as
a joke i'm thinking hey biz doc what do
you think about that like obviously
thinking he would just be fast asleep
and everyone would laugh the guys just
like
just closed the eyes he's like well if
you if we multiply the earnings ratio of
the of the the quadrant that's how he
sleeps yeah like the guy was just on
point while he was sleeping had the
answer i tried to set the biz doc up for
a joke he he no he didn't answer he gave
you very expensive
okay there you go
it's like ninjas ninjas don't sleep
because they have to be ready to kill
you do you remember last podcast when we
talked about the fake
guys that that online were commenting on
valuetainment using the vitamin logo
saying the fact that if you contact us
we're going to get a bitcoin
yes so i ended up calling them yeah
these fraudsters yes sir everywhere this
is i called them really kai and i and
sam and paul sat there yesterday we
contacted all these different whatsapp
accounts they put one of them responded
back
he called us we spoke to him probably
five times he hung up on me five times
yesterday but we finally got him on the
call and eventually he sent a message
back after our call maybe i'll show what
he said at the end to uh uh
what's up record the whole thing we had
the whole video
yeah so that was uh that was a pretty
interesting exercise that i think
everybody needs to kind of see because a
lot of that taking place and yesterday i
watched a video that uh has been
circulating the video with the uh the
first lieutenant
uh uh army uh soldier who had the cops
uh you just have to see this the guy who
gets pepper sprayed by the cops
exactly
pepper sprayed by the cup i watched the
whole thing last night 31 32 minutes and
it's pretty sad maybe we'll cover that
as well here it's disturbing it is very
disturbing so let's talk about the
topics that we got
united airlines hits back at pilot
training diversity criticism we'll get
into that bitcoin hits a trillion dollar
market cap three and a half times faster
than apple and two times faster than
amazon americans invested more in the
past five months in the than in the last
12 years we have to matter of fact why
don't we start off with that adam so we
can get that knocked out of the way
bernie madoff wall street financier and
ponzi scheme organizer died at 82 years
old yesterday tesla cfo is the latest
tech executive to buy a home in
texas jp morgan profit surges as bank
releases cash set aside for bad loans
softbank
uh uh backed grab agrees to deal to go
to public in world largest pack merger
ever coinbase ceo says ready folks
regulation is one of the biggest threats
to crypto you've been talking about i've
been saying this for years
dogecoin surges more than 85 in 24 hours
the winklevoss brothers the twins how
they went from losing facebook which
they didn't really lose facebook to
making trillions of dollars with bitcoin
and nft
the article says trillions obviously
didn't make trillions but that's what
the article's headline is amazon posts
its first hundred billion dollar quarter
this is q4 i think it was like 125
billion dollars we'll talk about that
the kenosha police officer who shot
jacob lake in the back has returned to
active duty without any discipline or
being charged minnesota police officer
who shot and killed dwante wright
dante wright has resigned the police
chief has also stepped down black army
officer pepper sprayed in traffic stop
accuses officers of assault we'll
discuss that maybe even show the video
us seeks to pause j j johnson johnson
covet 19 vaccine use after rare blood
clot cases
and uh fauci said we're putting this on
the pause for now biden to announce
withdrawal of u.s troops from
afghanistan by 9 11 september 11th
chinese fighters jets will fly over
taiwan to declare sovereignty state
media says
a real cool story about
julius randle with kobe bryant and the
next really really cool story and then
uh maybe we'll get into a story with
adam's fascination of elon musk's
girlfriend grimes
shares a topless video of her alien back
tattoo and details very elaborate design
process
this might be the number one story in
the world this may be the number one
story for you in the world yeah in the
galaxy i can in this galaxy and the
entire galaxy in the entire case okay
all right so let's start off with
americans invested more money in the
past five months than they did in the
last 12
years this is a fortune story over the
past five months over a half a trillion
dollars
has flowed into equity funds according
to a report from bank of america that's
more than that's more than the past 12
years combined there are a number of
reasons for the surging investments
individual investors have been
especially active as stocks like
gamestop amc
have been have seen big surges this year
thanks to reddit's wall street bets
community and overall optimism about the
pandemic has been on the rise since
early november 2020 when pfizer first
reported that trials uncovered 19vx and
showed it was 90 effective the market
themselves have have been helping spur
investment enthusiasm as well the s p is
now up 17 the past five months nasdaq
composite is up 27 the dow jones is up
27 approximately 569 billion has gone to
global equity since november in the
previous 12 months combined the total
was just 452 billion dollars thoughts
yeah the the um
the numbers are here we're gonna have to
break down some of these numbers but
just put yourself in the shoes of the
common investor
right especially younger people who
you're sitting at home
you're getting stimulus check after
stimulus check after stimulus check
there's been what three rounds of
stimulus checks
and there's been what five trillion
dollars pumped into the into the u.s
economy yep printed i learned digitally
not even necessarily
real
hard cash
and you're sitting at home you got
nowhere to go you got nothing to do
some people are going to maybe fix up
their houses but if you're a renter or
if you're just like looking to get
involved in the market where else are
you going to go so
traditionally 55 of americans have
invested in the stock market 80 of
americans have debt so they're looking
at the the the key to this article is
over the last five months
versus the last 12 years yeah five
months
versus 12 years that's right so it's 140
billion dollars more
in the last five months than the last
four people understand how much a
trillion is people don't understand how
much a trillion is
actually i actually ironically spoke
with ted koppel one time after a nalba
event ironically and he started talking
about the word the trillion he said and
he gave the analogy
if you go into if you went into business
with jesus your boy your main man you
went into business with jesus
two thousand and twenty something years
ago and you guys made a million dollars
a day a million dollars a day you
wouldn't even made a trillion dollars
just do some quick math for me 220 times
a million is what
220 million or 200 but we say if you
made a million dollars a day for a
million dollars
yeah what is that number well no you got
to do a million a day times 365 which is
365 million 365 million times 2 000
i think it's a trillion little under a
trillion
point that i'm getting do some fact
check call out ted koppel right now yeah
no ted cobbles smart
point is if you wanted the business of
jesus you made a million bucks a day for
the last 2000 years it wouldn't even be
a trillion so did you get some math for
me he's actually right 730 billion okay
that's my point 730 so if you and jesus
get into business a million dollars
every day 730 billion so you don't even
make a trillion so now you're talking
about infusing five freaking trillion
dollars into the economy and you're just
sitting at home nothing to do you hear
things like buy the dip because clearly
it dipped a year ago now the market's
making a comeback yep you know bonds are
paying nothing cash is paying nothing
um
the so what else are you gonna do with
your money you have elon musk i think
half of all people invested their money
based on an elon musk tweet like all
these ridiculous stats here's the
challenge though because obviously i'm a
big fan of the stock market it's amazing
it's awesome it's awesome but we're
talking over the last five months so all
these new investors potentially know is
up yup that all they know is the rocket
ship that's been going to the moon what
happens when the bubble bursts
and
you know the market goes down what
happens well i think the average so the
average consumer the average joe in the
street middle class is now seeing hey i
can join the party and there's a lot of
buzz come join the party the water's
fine the the market's up and they've got
reddit and it's happening to them on
mainstream uh main street bets but also
in the mainstream social media is
hitting them on facebook it's hitting
robin hood oh robin hood it's so easy
just click here click here click here
open yourself with a little account so i
think there's a name number one there's
a lot of buzz number two there's
enablers making it easy they can just
open up a robinhood account and they can
do it connect their checking account
bang done it did not used to be that
easy even open america raid account
remember that it was not easy just to
move even 500 bucks to start that
so now it's very easy there's a lot of
enablers there's a lot of buzz going out
there and people have the perception
that it's up up up and they don't
realize the ups and downs
and you know they're they've got time on
their hands and i also think what's
happening investment is i think a
reaction to
what they saw happening so i'm wondering
if also in middle class america they're
thinking maybe i do need to think a
little bit for myself here and do a
little bit of this because last year my
cousin was in real estate that sucked my
other cousin was in with cruise ships
that was terrible you know i think that
there's i think that there's also some
like maybe i need to do something here
but a lot of enablers and a lot of buzz
you know you know uh one time i read a
book called ageless man okay ageless man
so this guy was a pro steroids guy
pretty crazy story i'm about to tell you
right now
pro series guys it's a hardcore steroids
guys like listen you got to take
steroids like i got to take steroids i'm
telling you as you age you got to take
steroids but before you take it read
this book ageless man so i go buy this
book and i start reading it ageless man
and his argument was based on studies
they did on rats or whatever you know
it's real like studies they did on it
in the book i mean it could be making it
up but in the book i'm reading it that
they did studies
that
folks whose testosterone level drops
you die younger than those whose
testosterone level is higher
okay so you're looking at like okay
grains oh well this person does steroids
that person does growth hormone this
person does this and nowadays there's
the movement of doing what trt and
taking a little bit of uh you know gh
not the real big you know the whole gh
but slight gh right okay
who's right on the argument okay are the
arguments towards steroids are good or
steroids or bad historically we've been
told stories are what
bad for you right growth hormone is what
bad for you in some cases growth
hormones worked for many kids in some
cases steroids have worked for older
people a lot of times you'll see a 75
year old saying hey what happened to you
i just went to the doctor today they
gave me a shot of what a steroid shot
what steroid shot right okay you're
gonna see where i'm going with this um
you know the consequences of
being raised in a great community or bad
community the the the price of going to
private school kids become drug addicts
more at private schools than they do
public schools all these different data
that we get right hey you know if you
spoil them if you love them too much if
you discipline too much just side
effects of this okay
we have no clue what the side effects
are of giving people five trillion
dollars of funding we don't know there
is no market research on this we can't
go look at anywhere and say here's what
happens so everything we're experiencing
today is out of whack you don't know
what your body's reacting to today so
you can't sit there and say this is real
this is fake this is this so i'll tell
to people this is fake money so give the
argument this is fake money they'll say
well you know according to
what we're looking at right now nothing
has shown the fact that printing money
and putting money into the economy is a
bad thing nothing some experts will even
say that well okay so if that's the case
why don't we keep giving everybody a
trillion dollars every six months
if it's so great give everybody a
trillion dollars every six months let's
just fund it and see what happens
forget about people working let's just
keep giving people money they're gonna
invest into the stock market so if they
invest into stock market
who's gonna work at amazon for forty
five thousand dollars a year
if we're giving them money who's gonna
have a job so there has to be a part
where people realize
fake kind of success like this where
people invest more in five months than
12 years you can
in the world of sales like i run a sales
company
if one of your guys all of a sudden is
used to doing pick a number a hundred
thousand dollars a month
and for the last three years he's always
had a hundred thousand dollars a month
and he grows every year at a rate of 12
percent
so it's nothing crazy he grows at six to
12 percent the sales guy used to do a
hundred thousand now he's doing a
hundred and ten thousand i was doing 120
000 a month but it's generally around a
hundred thousand dollar number
all of a sudden he goes from a hundred
thousand like if you're talking about
five months 12 years that's what that's
24 times 25 times more if you really
break it down per month right like if
you take down
569 billion dollars let's let's actually
do the math on this kai do me a favor
and divide 452
divide that by uh 120 months divide that
by 120 months okay i'm gonna do 569
divided by five months
how much
452 divided by 120 months actually 12
times 244 months
okay here's here's the crazy number how
much
3.1 here's a crazy number you ready this
is the number
it says
569 billion dollars have gone into
equities in the last how many months
five months you divide it by five what's
the number 113.8
okay
you then it says what 452 billion
dollars in the last what 12 years how
many months in a year 12 12 times 12 is
what 144. you take 452 billion and you
divided by 144 on how much went into
equities every month 3.1
we went from 3.1 billion a month
to talking about 113.8
bill so so if you actually break that
down that's like a sales guy going from
doing 100 000 a month
let's do 113 divided by three is what
that's like a guy going from doing a
hundred thousand dollars a month to all
of a sudden he's doing 3.7 million
dollars a month that's crazy that was
that's crazy so you can't just sit oh my
gosh he's killing it great job what a
fantastic job he must be doing good you
have to be naive if you don't
investigate and say what the hell is
going on here there's got to be some so
there's two reactions to it there's
almost do you notice a level of panic
with people like oh my gosh i better get
my hands on the money that's being made
coinbase oh bitcoin
nft oh my gosh it's like it's like this
this anxiety is creating in everybody
sure okay you know what that's gonna do
that same anxiety and rush when you take
drugs when you take too much coffee when
you drink too much alcohol when you are
too much and you get off you know what
happens it's called the crash
now forget the market crash it's called
a crash within yourself how is how is
crash feel after you have 12 glass of
you know 12 cups of coffee how is crash
feel after you get off some kind of
drugs or alcohol what's the crash feel
like
and i'm talking about like a heavy duty
crash i'm not talking about like a you
know uh a light crash i'm talking about
like a real crash yep
it's extreme
you're like you're lethargic you can't
even get out my concern is
the crash is going to create the kind of
lethargic that we've not seen before i
hope i'm wrong but there is no
mathematical evidence that this works
i can't get it
there is no mathematical evidence that
this is good to sit there and say
fantastic how awesome is that you know
your kid is used to getting seven hours
of sleep all of a sudden your kid is
going on two hours of sleep for two
straight weeks and you sit there you
don't do anything with it you think it's
normal you have issues all right if your
kid is going out and you're like wait
what what what's going the other night
tycho great crazy story
tico never goes to sleep early
ever to the other dance like
uh
i'm gonna go to bed early
like what so i'm going to bed early
you're not going to bed early say no i
just want to go to bed early i'm tired
so i go to jen jen's like babe tico
never goes to bed early is something
okay with them i said i don't know let
me go see i go to his room okay he's
under his sheets okay he's nine so he's
not under his sheets at 14. he's under
she's at nine okay
so i look to see what he's up to
he's got the ipad under the [ __ ] i'm
like okay you don't wonder you're going
to bed early you don't ever go to bed
early he figured out a way to get that
ipad upstairs and he's playing a little
bit of video games because i had to get
the last uh what do you call it when the
game you got to get a screen out of a um
skin i had to get that skin i said what
is the skin he says it's like an nfd i
have to get that skin for this game i'm
like you literally when i took the ipad
came upstairs he says yeah so you have
to study trends there is something very
suspicious about the way the numbers are
growing and people cannot sit there and
say this is real you better
have some puts
you better have some defensive strategy
here you better be ready that if the
market hits and [ __ ] hits the fan what
is defensive
what is defensive okay defensive is gold
defensive is the complete opposite of
what everybody else is doing today you
just got to be ready today because this
to me doesn't feel real anyways i could
be wrong i'm speculating but none of
this stuff makes any sense to me well
number one kudos to tico for going to
bed early number two um
by the way we all just got a glimpse of
pat's
beautiful mind when it comes to math
that was freaking ridiculous i'm still
trying to like put a hundred billion
basically nothing i did was calculate
that was kind of ridiculous
no no no no
no no he
he he
it's called the perspective effect i
know you're a rocket scientist so for us
you know regular folks son of a rocket
scientist right son of a rocket
scientist literally
this son of a rock is it but um my major
point here is this
and you brought up a great point there's
so much stuff going on right now
coinbase ipo and the spac and the nfts
and the markets up in the fight it's
just like what you need to do if you're
home listening is just find your center
of gravity yeah and not compare yourself
to everyone else that's doing all this
and the winklevoss twins are making 10
trillion dollars and the guy down the
street my uber driver he's now a little
crypto billionaire it's like just figure
out your situation you know like we
talked about last time you know
crazy numbers of people are paying off
debt that's awesome right pay off your
debt save that money start getting
invested but have you know defense in
place and just find your center of
gravity because there's so much nonsense
going out there it's so easy to get
swept up with all the chaos and the
momentum that's going on that you said
the crash is inevitable whether it's
within yourself or whether it's the
market and just find your balance so
you're not what you just said there's
only evidence of the front half to pat's
point there's no evidence of the back
half about the responsibility setting
aside which you've earned on the
investments and being responsible and
prepared for the dark side there's
plenty of evidence what we just talked
about on the front side wow i got some
money some stimulus check what was it
two weeks ago government said that the
millennials and
some of the
older zs were actually investing their
stimulus checks you know because they
still had their job it was a
white-collar job it was an industry
wasn't very much affected they still had
their job so that they well guess what
here's some free money with the
government you know what
you used to get a free toaster when you
opened up a
a checking account at suntrust bank in
miami now they put now this is like the
government saying well here's a
brokerage account and here's almost two
thousand dollars go for it and you
brought up a good point
the gamification of stocks with robin
hood
yeah you know someone says happy
birthday on your iphone and you get all
the confetti or congratulations have you
noticed that robin hood i went and i
checked it out robin hood it does that
you have all this stuff it's yeah
everybody seen robin hood that when you
make a uh
a trade or something on robin hood they
give you there's this the screen effect
and so it's almost like they've turned
something that's very serious that
requires the level of caution into what
feels like a game yeah and with some of
uncle sam's money that was free so so
you know the whole thing with uh hey
save your money save your money save
your money cash your skin cash your
skincare save that money yeah no of
course save that money cash is king and
i'm a big proponent of that
but i'm also not for right now uh uh i'm
also even for the the investor that's a
smaller investor you put a little bit of
in in stuff that cannot be reprinted
you know in the last couple years i've
put i don't know nearly five million
dollars into cards okay yeah yeah i mean
what i mean everyday cards are coming
over here right now and not just
baseball cards not just basketball
and maryland no no i got and cary grant
the most crazy cars that come in right
now two weeks ago he had all the uh all
the 50s the glamour golden years of
hollywood that's the card yesterday i
got some very weird cards that came in
but i set them aside right why it cannot
be reprinted folks pay very close
attention to whatever can be reprinted
at any point decision made by the
government that's your competitor your
competitor says i'm going to reprint
money
that's pathetic if you can reprint money
it's like saying anybody can reprint the
1986 flea or michael jordan and hey flir
says we're going to reprint 10 million
of the cards out of those 10 million out
of cards right now there's only 315 of
them give or take
graded psa 10. you get 3 100 of them
created a psa 10 that card goes from 350
000 card 400 000 card to 50 000 card so
it's the reason why ken griffey's card
rookie upper deck 1989 is not worth 300
because there is a couple thousand of
them psa 10. it doesn't carry the same
weight whatever that gold cannot be
reprinted
cards cannot be reprinted unique art
cannot be reprinted we read this with
the article the other day from bank of
america the merrill lynch guy remember
the merrill lynch guy that we read about
start pay a little attention to that
because it can not be reprinted coastal
real estate you got to be very close
coastal real estate land yes i agree i
told high demand land anyways hey a
couple things if you
agree with what you just heard with the
fact that we have no clue what the hell
is going on
[Laughter]
if you say no we know what's going on
market's going to keep going up and
you're that optimistic
smash that thumbs down but i'm okay with
it but i'm going to tell you this here
this tequila is looking really good
right now because we can't figure
nothing out
when the live hits 3 500 i will have a
shot at tequila if it hits four thousand
i'll have one of each but at thirty
five thousand we're going to chug the
bottle what do you think
let's go for it it's five thousand we'll
do three of them here we go and i got
conference calls today how you doing i'm
doing
you know what great
okay we're doing this deal
speaking about coastal real estate real
quick yeah i'm sure a lot of our
listeners know we're in florida now
we're in boca raton florida
um and pat just did an awesome video are
you supposed to see it that way yeah of
course
um
the video
you messed me up here buddy the video i
thought it was boca raton i'm over here
irving or down from brooklyn we're here
for the winter was that a guy or wow
no that was a that was a uh that was was
that mort from family guy no no that was
that was like a woman an aunt who smokes
a little bit okay very nice very nice
tell us uh but you did a video called
why i moved to florida yep what inspired
that video for you to finally do that
because i moved to florida well we know
that sir
what
inspired you hundreds of messages
thousands of messages asking me are you
in florida did you move to florida why
are you in florida why'd you move to
florida why did you leave texas why did
you move to florida why'd you so i said
let me just do by the way 99 of videos i
make is an answer and respond to a
question
whoever asks the same question 100 times
200 times i eventually will make it most
of the time i feel like we should ask
the audience the number one question
right now whatever the next video it's
great i would i make i mean great so
when people ask me what are the rules to
money just watch this video how do you
handle this culture you go so anyways he
talked about that remember he said you
know if california and florida had a
bottle of tequila and got crazy
california and texas had a bottle of
terramanna and unprotected sex the
result would be maybe we play a game
just called just a tip i don't know we
might want to do that it's just a fun
guild game who knows it might just
happen people didn't get them no
that's a legendary actually i think
that's a really good quote by hoffman's
vince vaughn yeah no i think it's i
think we brought it was good if
california and texas had a baby
you know and we should do a whole
podcast on if the state's boinked and so
pick two states like of iowa and
illinois boynt what would you get hmm
west virginia you know you could do it
yeah what if new york and california had
a baby oh gosh france it would be a
trouble it'd be a troubled child
yeah okay all right let's go to the
united airlines story i don't know why
we haven't touched the story for the
last three weeks i said we get into it
ky if you want to pull it up on the
screen so people can see it
united airline hits back at pilot
training diversity and here's what they
have to say
this is a simple flying article okay
last week united airlines shared that it
has helped pledge 1.2 million on
scholarship fees to ensure its pilot
training school is more diverse overall
the united
aviate academy will train 5 000 new
pilots by 2030 with the goal of to have
at least 50 percent of the new students
be women or people of color however
this announcement was met with a mixed
reaction to which the chicago-based
carrier has now responded some people
voiced that the race and gender
shouldn't be a factor in hiring policy
they expressed that qualification should
be the key factor united share the
following on twitter to clarify the
hiring policy all the highly qualified
candidates we accept into the academy
regardless of race or sex will have met
or exceeded the standards we set for
admittance tom i'm gonna go to you first
with this one because i got strong
opinions on this one i got a very strong
opinion on this because there are
upstream problems or downstream problems
and conservatives like me tend to go
upstream and
unfortunately a lot of my liberal
friends tend to do downstream here's an
upstream and downstream problem so i'll
do metaphor quick there's a polluted
stream
okay so we're standing at the end of a
polluted stream and the liberal friend
says we need a multi-trillion dollar
filter to clean the stream and you're
going to pay for it over here whereas
the conservative goes wait a minute why
don't we go upstream and find out what's
putting the pollution in there and you
find a campsite and you find other
things putting crap in the water so you
say let's stop that and i think this is
an upstream downstream problem the
downstream isn't like in the hiring
office that you should be hiring you
know people that are not as qualified
just so you can meet some sort of quota
on diversity i want to say how do we go
upstream and enable more people of color
and diverse backgrounds to get into
flight school when they're 20 years old
how do we make it attractive um you know
career so people thinking about it can
get into flight school so at the end of
the day people with five years of flight
school experience and they got their
license and multi-engine they've gone
through this whole thing and now we have
a natural diversity because there's a
bunch of qualified people from all kinds
of backgrounds because we go upstream
and we attract them i'm not big on
downstream problems like this it says at
the end of the day you have to make
certain compromises and i don't think
air safety is a place to do it should we
have more people of color and women in
the cockpit yes but let's go upstream
and make it attractive for them to go
get educated and they'll compete for the
job like everybody else and they'll be
great qualified pilots of all kinds of
backgrounds that the average person can
feel perfectly great about whoever is
flying their plane interesting
interesting analogy what do you think
the whole time he's talking about
upstream downstream i'm just thinking of
tom sawyer tom with his uh just doing
his thing yeah that was what was on my
mind very interesting
don't mess with me i'm on a roll you're
on a roll so here's where i'm going with
this because i did an episode a couple
months ago called the nasdaq's gone woke
and um
ariana friedman i believe is her name is
the president of the nasdaq and she's
basically implementing all these rules
within the nasdaq
about diversity
and inclusion
and how many board members have to be
female or you know of a certain color
and
for the most part she was implementing
this throughout the nasdaq and it was
sort of met with for the most part good
reviews okay and
whether you know so basically here's my
point i'm all for
inclusion and diversity and when the
nasdaq nasdaq went woke i was you know
kind of with that here's the flip side
of that
i'm all for that until you know i'm
flying on a plane the only freaking
thing i care about is getting to where
i'm going safely
this is the one time where i'm just like
yo
i don't give a [ __ ]
if there's
10 000 white guys and they're all pilots
i could care less about diversity if
they all just get me to where i'm going
safely this is the one time where
this is this this whole attack on you
know
white people for the most part i just
can't play that game with um with flying
just because flying
i mean look how many plane crashes have
happened over the last five years
like i don't remember a time other than
9 11 when planes were just going down
boeing how many have you ever done a
case study on boeing what's happening
with them i i actually did a uh a beer
in business uh conversation with phil
kondit the ex-ceo of boeing of course
and he talked about the 737 maxinet
so
to me scaring flying what i'm saying is
that was an aircraft issue okay that was
a bad design in there that that uh
there's issues that's going on i mean
software then certain conditions yeah
so but
safe flying especially these days is
such a concern and i there's you see
grown men in planes that just like
scared to fly the number one thing is
making sure the pilots and the planes
are safe this is not the place to start
playing the whole kit
bbd so okay so let's talk about this
first of all uh the statement is made
saying what that the fact that
uh 50 are going to be new students are
going to be women or people of color
right okay do you know what percentage
of americans are black african americans
probably 13 percent 13 point 13 13 to 16
okay 13.4
which means
united airlines is essentially becoming
racist against whites to not write no
not higher whites if you're going to go
this is a mathematical conversation
you're like go go down i'm going to go
deeper for you
know those females this is let me know
this is a mathematical conversation
they're having here it's pure math for
me okay here's the other thing for you
uh what percent of ob gyn is men and
women 10 years ago what percentage of ob
gyn is men
or women 10 years ago the last time i
went to an ob gyn what do you think i
mean i'm just asking you what do you
think i would say 80 men do you think 80
men what do you think i thought i would
think you say 10 years ago 10 years ago
i would say 10 years it was probably 90
men still okay it was 57 men today it's
55 women okay but it used to be men
before now it's women okay flipped a
little bit
it is what it is okay nurses
nurses what percentage of nurses
according to u.s bureau of labor
statistics are men today what percentage
of nurses are men today male what
percentage like a male 13
like a gaylord falker yeah what
percentage are nurses
i'm gonna go with 30. 30. what do you
think
according by to pull it up what
percentage are men what do you think it
is i would say 10 20 years ago i would
say 80 20 female to male i would say
it's closer to 60 40. watch the number
here pull it up according to 12 percent
we're not even another researcher only
are men today nurses are we going out
there saying this is racist
this is sexist why are only 12 men and
by the way 40 years ago 50 years ago was
only 2.7 percent i think it says 1970
was 2.7 percent right so so so the point
is this is not about you ever force
somebody to do something what happens to
them when you force someone to do
something do they like it do people like
force they don't like it united airlines
trying to force people to want to be
pilots dude i don't want to be a pilot
what if i'm a woman and i don't want to
be a pilot it's force it's
mathematically
not the right direction to go and quite
frankly to me
united airlines is being racist against
people
this is not the you cannot win in this
argument there is no winning in this
argument there's no way you can win in
an argument like this you sit there and
say hey you know i noticed
your friends uh the percentage of your
friends not enough of them are are
white and not enough of them are asian
and not in when i grew up a hundred
percent of my friends were armenian what
does that make me racist
when i went into the army and i was at
the hundred first airborne division air
assault guess what eighty percent of
them were white
and nineteen percent were black and then
it was you know you put a little latino
on there but you pretty much so majority
were white then it's blacks then it's
latinos then it's asians and the rest so
what if the military is racist so
it it you cannot have the same thing be
the case in every single industry it's a
couple things you look at here now let's
flip it let's flip and let's just say i
did a video the other day for the
armenian community
and the armenian community video that i
did i call that parents i call that
armenian parents is what i did flat out
i said armenian parents i'm talking to
and i spoke in armenia
and i rarely do this i don't do armenian
videos so they say can you please speak
in armenia because people wonder if you
speak armenian or not i said i speak a
little bit armenian but it's street
armenia and i don't speak like armenia
proper armenian so i spoke to our
minister can we get a sample i'd love to
hear i said i'd like to i'd like to
speak to the parents and then i said
you know mama papa says
i want to talk to you guys about what
you're doing with your kids today
raising them right got it i said stop
telling your kids that unless they
become doctors lawyers dentist attorneys
they're not successful stop saying that
to your kids
stop saying that they have to be a
doctor lawyer dentist okay
you know what it does it creates the
pressure for the kid to be a what
something he doesn't want to be i had a
guy a girl at ucla medical center she
was what do you call the doctors that's
for eye what's the uh optical
ostomologist so she sits there persian
girl beautiful girl i saw how long you
been doing this for 15 years how do you
like your job can i close the door so
yeah sure she closed the door i hate my
job what then why you've been doing it
for 15 years because i make too much
money that i can't leave why did you
become an ophthalmologist to make
my parents happy to make my parents
happy i am miserable she went on a
10-minute rant i was doing an executive
health stuff that this guy recommended
me to do at ucla tom she went on a 10
minute rant about how much she hates my
job and then she says let me check your
eyes
how your eyes are after she said it is
what it is it depends on the thing
so the point is to force people to do
something they don't want to do
flip it let me go now the other side of
the argument okay so
take any nationality any nationality
like when i talk to the jewish community
i'm like why do jewish
folks typically you know they get judged
for doing well financially oh because
you guys are cheap what does that really
mean when you say jews are cheap what do
you mean by jewish people are cheap why
are you guys cheap
why this is it in your blood
is your blood dna like a type c
and it's what the cheap is that what the
blood type is or is it because when you
were raised in a church in a you know
whatever you went
synagogue your family the thing is save
your money do this be frugal maybe the
values that were taught that you were
growing up had to do with that right
okay
maybe
the middle eastern community has to
encourage more entrepreneurship maybe
the black african-american community
they need to teach folks to want to go
into business more i don't know maybe
become like i was in chicago one time
doing an event at ritz carlton
and i walked in no joke i walked in 2
sharp
black african american kids
18 19 20 year old kids okay
looking like a million bucks guys and
girls i said what's going on over here
we are part of this uh lawyer whatever
future lawyers uh black lawyers of
america i see you gotta be kidding me no
where did the inspiration come for this
barack obama get out of here fantastic i
love that because that is like you're
encouraging to go out and want to become
lawyers there you go are people waking
up saying hey son i want you to grow up
and be a pilot no one says go be a pilot
a kid becomes a pilot because almost
every person that's a pilot they're a
pilot because their parent was a pilot
or because they're like
i love playing with these planes and
what if one day you don't force somebody
to become a pilot they choose to become
a pilot so this is a publicity stunt
that makes them look like fools is what
it does for united airlines to make a
comment like that here's what we're
going to do moving forward go study math
and study data it doesn't work in your
favor and it's quite offensive when you
say here's what we're going to move and
how about the rest of us
how about the wrestlers when you say
something like that no i don't i don't
like their marketing approach they took
and quite frankly it's just to try to
get some people to say
oh they are very diverse today and
they're willing to work with everybody
they don't work too well for me but
there's something that really had me
revved up uh recently is um bailey's
thinking about colleges looking around
and doing her research and she's looking
at yale she's looking at pen she's
looking at vanderbilt and things like
this she's got the grades and i'm like
you study what you want to study so we
can do a whole discussion about that i'm
not directing her one way or the other
i'm just saying whatever you study in
college make it useful i'm not going to
pay for you to go to france and study
you know the history of art you know i
don't know what you would do with that
if you really want to do that we can
talk but
we we stumbled onto this pbd very very
interesting yale was suddenly
you know
she's studying uh she googles
yale at missions there's this massive
lawsuit where caucasians and asians were
saying
that yale was so horribly
overcompensating that they were actually
discriminating against caucasians
of asians having anything close to a
fair shot to get into the school
and
so they took him to court
yale on the you can't prove that we did
it you can't prove that we really
conspired among the admissions committee
there's no emails there's not that you
can't prove we conspired and said what
are you talking about look at look at
these people that got in look at the
diversity of that look who didn't get in
and let's go look at test scores and
let's look at you know capabilities and
achievement now there's a place for
scholarship and there's a place to get
people step up what they don't want to
talk about
is that a lot of these kids that were
that got in so that yale could say we
are so diverse we are wondering so yale
gets the marketing right yale gets
social pressure off their back because
hey we're being diverse and guess what
happens
a higher percent of those kids are
flunking out at the end of sophomore
year with big student loans because
yale's not cheap and they were not their
100 scholarships
get it so now yale gets the merit badge
but you actually do somebody a non-favor
at times when you open doors pressure
it's pressure to act like you are
all-inclusive and it backfires on you
because you pissed somebody off look uh
in our comments i'm saying it backfires
on some of these people that we're at of
course there's poor people now giant
students look at our company look at our
company like
insurance company php okay we're 50
latino okay
we just are it's like okay we're 50
latino then we're 25 african-american
our caucasian is 13
what am i going to do
do we make that up that sound in the
background i hear something that's
coming up i don't know what that is
okay can you guys hear it or not it went
away for a second but do you still hear
it or no
i do
is this still there okay so so you look
at how did this happen did i say
here's what the percentage needs to be
this is what this needs to be or did we
just become like that because it come
and i'm from iran so i'm middle eastern
i'm christian i'm armenian i'm a syrian
how did i attract latinos how did i
attract it's just the culture of the
company that this took now by the way
the industry
is
what percentage percent white i would
say maybe even the average agent is a 59
year old white male you go to the
traditional insurance industry
everyone's white you know we're okay
it's a multicultural that's what
happened to us because that's what we
talked about we would like to be a
multicultural company somebody in here
said
two people said f obama and another
person said yeah
you know
f obama uh
i don't i don't subscribe to that
mindset by the way politically
philosophically we are on complete
opposite ends when by the way and i will
say right now today as crazy as this
sounds barack obama today is more like
john f kennedy than it was 15 years ago
barack obama's not the barack obama of
2005. barack obama's not the barack
obama of 2010. barack obama today ever
since he started getting paid and he's
gonna have a life to live for another
four years he's starting to realize we
can't just tax everybody today's barack
obama is a different barack obama 10
years ago but go back and say f obama
um
i applaud competitors
who think long term
and for republicans who get upset and
they say f obama no f your strategies is
what i say your strategies suck why
don't you get together and put some good
strategies together because democrats
are out strategizing you and it pisses
you off go get pissed off about the
strategies you're getting putting
together rather than getting pissed off
at somebody else on the opposing get
that's doing a better job than you you
got to salute your competitors it's
simple as that rather than getting upset
at the competitor you got to say what
salute i respect you i've lost
throughout my career god knows how many
times i've lost and i've sat there and
said damn more power to them good for
them let's sit down and look and see
what we're doing here wrong that they're
doing right maybe we can learn from it
that's the one part that sometimes
politically people become blinded oh f
trump oh f obama oh nope strategy
strategy strategy take a step back and
look what's going on and quite frankly i
just don't like
united airlines strategy we had somebody
that just commented i want to read her
comment
uh she just gave five bucks and she said
um julia swenson she says you can't pick
and choose
everything should be based on
qualifications i don't want to be hired
anywhere because i'm a girl it's
ridiculous that's what julie just said
right
then kevin gave five bucks and he says
question number one should there be any
diversity requirement
in companies and number two shouldn't we
focus on skill experience and character
when hiring okay let's answer each
question should there be any diversity
requirement for companies what do you
think tom yeah i think companies should
uh have to prove that they have a
non-discriminatory open door to receive
anyone of any background so that the
selection process can be completed i
think there has to be there has to be i
i must i think there must be look are
you letting
anyone
you know you know show up at the front
door in fact google did something very
interesting you know what they did they
took names and cities off resumes and
they had hiring managers looking at the
resumes and guess what they found out
they found out that they had a more
neutral selection process that there was
there were little things in the back of
people's minds that were thinking about
oh this person comes from daly city i
wonder if they went to a good college i
wonder where they come from whereas this
one came from oh it was in uh you know
atherton then went to stanford oh must
be a really smart person so they took a
lot of this stuff off and also they did
a little um uh
you know ethnic analysis you know
lashika jones hmm you know it it has a
cultural conversation to it that you
might assume when they took all that out
they got more neutralness i think
companies should be held to are you
allowing every person regarding a
background their resume to get in and be
part of the filtering process are you
allowing that to happen and so then from
there are you just do you show that you
have a fair and reasonable this is our
criteria we need a pilot pilot has to
have this many hours in the sky has to
have this and then we evaluate how many
of these people have that we'll take the
best one and if it happens to be a white
guy it's a white guy happens a hispanic
woman that's a hispanic woman just to
build on what you're saying
qualification should be the first and
foremost factor when hiring i feel like
then there's then there's other factors
yeah race sex all that kind of stuff
like that so i'll give you a couple
different examples raise adam by five
percent go ahead keep going five percent
i'll just speak into the mic well in the
nfl they have something called the
rooney rule you're familiar with the
rooney rules um basically
every nfl team when they're looking for
a candidate has to hire i'm sorry
consider hiring a black candidate it's
the rooney rule so when you have mike
tomlin that got his job who basically
was the youngest coach to ever win a
super bowl for the pittsburgh steelers
he potentially a decade or so ago before
he got the job
wouldn't have been in the running so to
speak but now because of the rooney rule
he was a they had to interview a black
candidate he turned out to be a great
candidate point is that's just the
rooney rule in the nfl where i don't
know kai if you want to pull it up
rooney rule
an nfl team has to consider
within their candidates a black
candidate a couple different things when
it comes to qualifications now there's
there's some qualifications you get
percentages of people who are nurses you
get percentage of people
um
who different jobs what percentage of
male or female are construction workers
it's it's night and day exactly sure so
99 of a guy just commented saying why
don't we have all the women go become
rec layers and see what happens
noel zinterman said let's make 50 a
female bricklayer quota play their game
and see how long they'll be there we go
what percentage of people are okay so
now obviously you know i go out in south
beach what percentage of
bottle servers waitresses are men
no they're 100 female because when
you're buying bottles and you're
spending thousands of dollars at the
club you want some hot chicks coming
over with sparklers that's just part of
the game so can a guy bring a bottle
over to your table just as well as a
female yeah sure but i don't want six
dudes rolling up at my table when i'm
buying bottles bring some chicks over
there that's just the game that we're
playing yeah so qualifications are great
but then age sex color that is a factor
i'm sorry
yeah so so let me give you some data
hockey what percentage of hockey players
are black one percent two percent it's
five percent 43. that's actually good
for them
five percent of hockey players are black
43 percent 43 hockey players are black
today three of them are for detroit red
wings it's a record first time ever
where one team has three of them they
got three of them on there
nfl nfl 70 are black okay so so
that's nba nba is probably even a bigger
number what percentage of uh what
percentage of i'm guessing nba players
are
nba 74.2 percent okay nba
so does that make nba racist
no they're just a lot of people are
better does that make sense does that
make nhl racist no does that make nfl
racist
nhl is 95 black 95 white is it racist
nba is 74.2 percent black are they
racist nfl is 70 black are they racist
against others no here's what it is kids
are growing up if you really want to see
a change in this if a black kid
is playing with dad what what game is
dad playing is that playing hockey is
that playing baseball playing basketball
what's that playing right whatever that
game is i tell you one thing with me
guess what you ain't playing if you're
my kid
you ain't playing hockey if you're my
kid i'm not calling how the hell to play
hockey god knows dylan could have ended
up being one of the greatest hockey
players of all time that gets to play
he ain't never going to play hockey with
daddy he could have been the first
armenian a syrian
hockey player
i'm sorry he has the wrong father for
that
what you're saying so the game is if
people want to make a change in any of
these areas it starts off with the top
with the most influential people saying
hey why don't you consider getting into
politics why don't you consider getting
into business why don't you consider
getting into real estate why don't you
consider going and starting some
businesses why don't you it's that why
don't you consider from the top and the
kid typically will be inspired by what
that community leader and parents tell
them to do anyways we can get away from
the story one question let's see if you
guys got final one
a sport that came to mind why the united
states completely just
shits the bed for some reason soccer
it's soccer yeah why are the men suck
but the women are good i don't
understand that that's just one thing
but there was a speech
it was a black businessman years ago in
front of a group of um african-american
kids and he basically broke down the
odds of becoming an nba player he's
basically all you all want to get to the
nba let me break down some stats for you
there's
a half a million high school basketball
players there's
10 000
college basketball players there's 500
nba players so if you're the one of 500
000 um
basketball players that play in high
school the chances you make it to the
nba are point zero zero zero zero one
whatever go become something else don't
hinge all your dreams becoming a
basketball player i'm an entrepreneur
become a businessman i agree jimmy
valvano talked about that he said um i
was asking these kids i was talking
about graduation and i mean what do you
want to study here at nc state what do
you want to do and they said i want to
i'm going to go to the nba i'm going to
go to the nba so the three the three uh
recruited freshmen they're sending us
off
do you know that there's only 17 there
will be 17 players in the draft
that actually are in the nba after three
years
each year in college there'll be 17
players that are still in the nba after
three years and he says
young men it's a really amazing day
because i just recruited three of them
here at nc state
there you go so the point he's trying to
make right he's trying to make a simple
point is that hey you know what
you do that low percentage but we're
we've gotten far field
i think to put a period on it i think
we should be sure that companies are
giving everybody a fair shot 100 but it
should and there should be recourse when
they're not
but it's got to be you know based on
skills yeah let's hire based on white
black latino asian middle eastern and
right
and let's go upstream and invest more in
schools and to do the things so that
kids have more capabilities and more
places to go i agree so let's go
upstream not try to fix it down i swear
to god we're all going to go find a
river this weekend and try to swim
upstream that's what i'm you guys up for
i said we do this this weekend while
having tequila huckleberry yeah by the
way 28 19
at 3 500 we're gonna have a shot at
tequila okay four thousand we may do two
of them so let me let me respond to some
of the comments here corrupted pat i'm a
huge fan will you please address the
uh mlm pyramid scheme and other issues
you know they bring i'm honestly listen
let me just tell you this i will not
respond to that video but i will tell
you this i have a video corrupted i'm
going to put a video here for you to
look at
corrupted go in the comments section i
did this video four years ago i
responded to john oliver video
if you want to know more about it it's a
40 minute video and corrupted i wrote a
42 page ebook free for you to look at
exactly what i think about different
sales models and what i think about
different multi-level marketing models
and you can go definitely take a look at
that and that should answer a lot of
your questions for you jonathan latimer
said if barack obama did a good job
we would not have gotten trump people
are fed up with the status quo i don't
disagree with jonathan latimer
that we have uh uh trump because of
obama i don't disagree with that i also
don't disagree that we have biden
because of trump either i think there's
an element of that taking place uh
ronald said if i identify as a female
should a strip club for men be forced to
hire me if identified as a female should
a strip club depends how you look bro
depends how you look okay there you go
adam knows a few if you need to get in
contact with come us shout out to my
friends at 11 down in miami military
academy so here's mark the marina
military academy and have seen firsthand
uh seeing what aa does people from rural
and poor areas regardless of race are
more often remedial okay interesting joe
adam the women's national soccer team
lost to boys under 16 development team
wow
the women's national soccer team u.s
national soccer team lost to a boys
under 16 development development team
men's competition is harder plain and
simple
there you go that's joel next topic
interesting the women's topic next topic
next topic let's go into
uh
papa papa which story do we want to
touch upon let's go to china fighter
jets we'll fly over taiwan to declare
sovereignty state media says go to page
six
uh
let me take a look at this i don't
really get this okay so let's read it
okay china fighter will jet will flow
over taiwan to declare sovereignty
state media says newsweek story chinese
fighter will flower towns under the
declaration of relations between
washington and taipei continue to
improve a prominent state media figure
set after beijing sent 25 warplanes
toward the island on monday chief editor
of china's nationalistic communist party
newspaper the global times said the
people's liberation army would step up
military pressure in the event of a
further warming of u.s taiwan ties if
taiwan forces open fire that will be the
moment of all-out war across the taiwan
strait the people's republic of china
claims ownership of democratic taiwan
despite having never governed it in
seven decades since its founding
after the chinese civil war taiwan
continues to be a run as the de facto
state that maintains several unofficial
yet crucial global partners in an
ambiguous existence known as the status
quo adam
well we touched on this i believe in the
last podcast about china and their
relationships with their surrounding
countries taiwan being specific
um
we might be here in america this this is
all it all comes down to perspective and
putting yourself in someone else's shoes
we here in america think well who cares
taiwan whatever this is a huge deal for
china
huge deal for china so on the on the
outside perspective you know we have a
list of topics we're going through our
live we got the million different things
we're dealing with blm and antifa we got
things going on here that we care about
we hear taiwan uh whatever whatever's
going on myanmar gives a [ __ ] yep for
china this is a huge deal this is the
quote-unquote proverbial red line that
they don't want anybody crossing so
you know they talk about in world war
one when the archduke ferdinand was
assassinated and that
you know spouted off this powder keg
that
led to world war one which eventually
led to world war ii yada yada yada yada
this is the type of thing
you know knock on wood cross your
fingers that could potentially lead to a
world war three where something small
that affects a country more than you
understand can lead to something massive
and for china apparently it's this
taiwan thing
i did this is basically
a
50 year old by-product of the revolution
and chiang kai-shek you know going
across
you know what you have here it's
unresolved and to those of us in the
west you should really think of it as
east and west germany that was
unresolved for so long right and then
there was reunification and so after
world war ii we had this split and we
had berlin the berlin wall and
everything that goes with that and china
sees this the same way this is the way
they see it that was once part of us it
should still be part of us and this is
what's what's going on and you know if
taiwan
i would as my father i was in uh taipei
taiwan um on october 8th to 10th
and on this goes back 1999
and
at my hotel i hear rumbling outside on
the morning of october 10th it was kind
of funny and they caught the double ten
festival 1010 october 10th
and it was the celebration of their
independence so there was a lot and i
saw i saw tanks out there and military
things in the street it was it was not
the russian military this is in taiwan
this is in taiwan it was not a russian
military mayday where everybody would
you pull up taiwan on the map where
they're all clapping politely but you're
you're supposed this is what year this
is 99. okay and so this bypass called
the double 10 festival happens every
year in taiwan um
taiwan double ten day right there at the
top and it's sunday october 10th it's a
national day republic of china
public holiday annually see and what
they do is they celebrate their
independence there is a lot of
patriotism in the street i saw it there
was like this there were parades there
was activities there was military in the
street but it wasn't military like
russian mayday like power military it
was celebration like when we have planes
fly over the super bowl you know i mean
it was that kind of celebration and
stuff and so there is a lot of pride now
of four generations in taiwan of people
who feel wait we're independent i'm
taiwanese and we're independent and
china's like no this is like world war
ii reunification of germany i want that
back look at even the map right now i
mean obviously hong kong is in the news
because hong kong is attached to
mainland china it's sort of like a
peninsula on the on the um
south well the same thing happened to
hong kong look at taiwan it's an island
off of china is that right kai might
look at seeing that right yeah okay so
from a
geographical standpoint taiwan is not
even attached to china so i can see
why with that but here here's what i
want you to do i want you to go to the
heritage
index of economic freedom do you have
that up
heritage index of economic freedom
this is a site that shows you which
countries
are the most economically free countries
in the world go to see all rankings to
the right
bottom right
bottom right right there okay check this
out
close the okay
free meaning 100 to 80
how free they are number one is
singapore number two is new zealand then
australia then switzerland and ireland
freest countries
in the world okay let's keep going look
who's number six i think six or six is
taiwan wow okay taiwan is free freer
than america then it's uk then it's
estonia then canada then marked in
iceland then georgia then
mauritius then uh united arab emirates
then lithuania you still don't have us
by the way netherlands finland
luxembourg chile united states united
states is behind uae think about that
then he got sweden malaysia let's go to
the other side uh japan south korea
austria israel israel czech republic
norway germany latvia qatar armenia
armenia shout out to armenia 30 seconds
cyprus kazakhstan bulgaria malta belgium
hello
john 38. now we're going to moderately
free
spain bahrain poland thailand romania
uruguay jamaica you see all these
countries there jordan bahamas
you're about to see it as you go lower
and lower russia is 92 by the way look
at the main countries russia is 92.
france is 64. mexico 65 okay italy
tanzania
93 el salvador 94 greece 96 now you're
going to mostly unfree go ahead okay
honduras south africa
benin ghana trinidad
uh gambia nigeria uganda china 107.
107. uzbekistan mostly phone free
egypt burma and you see some of these
countries okay along with lots of uh
brazil brazil 143 afghanistan 146.
argentina 140.
149 pakistan 152
okay belize tom 114 belize lebanon 154
haiti
india 121
is what india is okay
go lower now let's see the one that says
repressed
gotcha see if you see any big company
countries here algeria
iran 168 cuba 176 north korea last
venezuela second to last
then it's cuba the bottom three that are
actually ranked are north korea
venezuela and cuba and go below it go
below it go below it you got iraq libya
lichtenstein
somalia
syria and yemen here's what's crazy at a
cuba venezuelan south north korea which
of those three you think is most likely
to be mostly free
which of those three things is most
likely to be free venezuela cuba or
north korea i have my guess
what do you think well it's not north
korea so not north korea
it's really now
uh venezuela i'm going to say cuba i
think cuba is more likely to be free
than venezuela
uh i it's just a hunch i think it's
closer i think it's
you know the influence i think venezuela
is second and i think north korea is
still but the point is going back to the
taiwan conversation go all the way to
the top china doesn't want taiwan to
have an email also look also how uh this
is five and then it goes to 25 i mean
dramatically different gap between these
three a little bit yeah
like north korea versus any other
country
it's a dramatic camp yeah i would love
to see at the very very very top
um and pat had a great point well the
guy killed two cousins in his brother
what the qualifications are for being
free quote unquote like did they give a
yeah read oh this well here it is rule
of law so they're they're out there
government size regulatory efficiency
open markets trade freedom investment
freedom business freedom
fiscal household but by the way they
have it on three under each so rule of
law is property rights uh judicial
effectiveness government integrity then
you got government-sized tax burden
government spending fiscal health
regulatory efficiency business freedom
labor freedom monetary freedom then you
got trade freedom investment freedom
financial freedom it's not so go to us
i want to see government integrity for
the u.s i want to see our score there
number two 20.
click on us open open our card
here we go let's see what we're
excelling at
okay
monetary freedom we're doing well in
fiscal health 35 that's a terrible score
by the way to be at 34.9
open markets trade freedom okay
government spending 62 tax burden 76.
interesting when you look at this
judicial effectiveness effectiveness
government integrity 76.8
its overall score is degrees by 1.8
points primarily because of a decline in
fiscal health yeah you're printing money
the united states is ranked third among
32 countries so america's region so why
would china want taiwan to stay free
they wouldn't want
taiwan to stay free because taiwan
politically and philosophically is the
complete opposite that's correct china
so the more taiwan excels and people
from china have a place to leave to the
more that makes china look bad by the
way didn't they just have
u.s had a couple of ships right that
went through
the the the south china sea south china
straight yeah between the two a ship
went through it china wasn't too happy
about it because china is saying u.s is
meddling in the relationship between
them and taiwan
um
by the way you know what's a big
conversation that's taking place right
now the possibility of war like more and
more people are saying the likelihood of
having a war right now is hiding hiding
in a long time everything that's going
on in crimea with russia yeah and
america's meddling in it so some are
saying why is america meddling gonna
just leave them alone with taiwan and
america saying wait a minute why
wouldn't we
help support
some of the folks there that are
believing in many of the philosophies
that we believe in china saying no you
got to get out of it it's none of your
business let us deal with taiwan it's
none of your business there's a huge
economic interest in taiwan if you take
a look at the made in taiwan made in
china made in vietnam made in the
philippines it is a it is a huge
manufacturing island to a lot of us
companies huge
and yeah
taipei's here china's here they don't
want america right in this area well
we'll see what's going to happen here
can you do me a favor and pull up the
video with a black army officer pepper
sprayed in traffic stop accuses officers
of assault i'm going to read the story
while you're bringing it up we'll watch
it but i'm first going to read the story
go to page 5
all the way at the bottom page five all
the way at the bottom
black army
officer pepper sprayed in traffic stop
accuses officer of assault this is a new
york times story
karen nazario quran nazario lieutenant
in the us army medical corps was driving
to petersburg virginia from a drill
weekend when he saw police lights
flashing behind him too nervous to stop
on a darkened road lieutenant nazario
who was black and latino drove about a
mile to a gas station pulled over and
placed the cell phone on his dashboard
immediately two windsor police officers
can be heard yelling orders at him
lieutenant nazario then says i'm
honestly afraid to get out of the car
yeah you should be says one of the
officers according to the footage from
his body camera seconds later the
officer accused
uh
dues the lieutenant with pepper spray
lieutenant azaria hands remained up as
he coughed and pleaded with the officer
to undo his seatbelt and made sure the
dog's smoke was not choking in the back
lieutenant zarya has filed a lawsuit
accusing the officers of illegally
searching his car using excessive force
and violating his rights under the first
amendment the lawsuit seeks one million
dollars income compensat compensatory
can i pull up the video let's take a
look at this so this is a shorter video
that we can show i want you to see this
and let's i want to have a reaction to
this but i want you to see this here the
longer one is 31 minutes we're just
gonna use a five minute one we may not
even watch the whole thing but we'll
mount some of the clips of it lower the
audio a little bit
okay pull up
go a little bit fast like yeah there you
go this is good
a little more
a little
more many occupants are in your vehicle
open the door slowly step out
open the door
get out of the car
open the door slowly get out
this is december 5th 2020. so four
months ago
the guy that's screaming was a corporal
in the marines
his wife was a sailor in the navy not
the guy on camera the guy in the back
that has the camera outside the window
keep your hands outside the window the
guy screaming is a former marine car
now
he has both of his hands out
he's in army fatigue
he's an army fatigue
yo well guess what i'm a veteran too i
learned to obey get out of the car yep
watch this
get out of the car now
what's going on is you're fixing to ride
the lightning son
i'm saying you're about to ride the ride
the lightning sun he's going to taste
the car now
get out of the car now
get out of the car sir just get out the
car
work with us and we'll talk to you get
out the car you're receiving our order
obey it i'm
i'm
i'm honestly afraid get out can i yeah
you you should be get out
get out now i have not committed any
crime you're being stopped for a traffic
violation you're not cooperating at this
point right now you're under arrest
right for you're being detained okay
you're being detained for obstruction of
justice
by the way the guys being so reasonable
really get up get out of the car now get
out of the car
get out of here get your hands off me
you know what get your hands off man
back up
don't do that sir get out of the car now
okay watch this get out of the car now
sir i'm trying to get out okay i'm
trying to i'm gonna talk get out
can you please relax get out he's
relaxed get out of the car right now
now that's not how you treat a vet uh
i'm actively serving this country and
this is how you're going to treat me
i didn't do it whoa hold on what's going
on
[Applause]
spraying pepper spray
gosh
get out of the car
get out of the car now
there's a better angle
sir just get out the car
get out of the car now
yeah open get out of the car and get on
the ground now you're going to get it
again
i i don't even want to be surprised
i don't believe you get out of the car
get out of the car now
you can't see pepper spray in his eyes
he's struggling
take off your seatbelt and get out of
the car
look i'm just gonna just
he knows if he puts his hands down
then somebody can shoot him and
potentially say
watch this
take your seatbelt off and get out of
the car
don't reach in daniel don't reach in
there
there's a gun in here by the way he has
a gun in here and they know they saw it
really messed up
he's the first lieutenant officer get
out of the car
there's a dog in the truck
smoke is his name
i'm a lieutenant lieutenant get out of
the car says what are your specialists a
corporal he says i'm a lieutenant you
made this way more difficult it had to
be if you just comply
specialist is an e4
a first lieutenant you have to go to
college to get a degree then you become
a lieutenant straight under the ground
such a good citizen here
let's go
let's go available
being respectful
get on the ground
now
get on the ground you're getting sprayed
again get on the ground can you please
talk to me about stay on the ground shut
the ground now
please talk to me
can you please talk to me about you
extremely respectful still the entire
time
why am i being treated like this you're
not cooperating get on the ground
okay fast forward
what's up
okay unfortunately we can't show the
whole clip because we were trying to get
approval on the other video to get
approval we haven't gotten it back yet
but uh uh when you see the whole clip
eventually at the end uh the cop tries
to explain to him look i understand
where you are why did you do this to
yourself you did this to yourself you
shouldn't have done this you did this to
yourself if you would have listened this
would have never happened etc etc and
the guy's just sitting there saying dude
he didn't say nothing he's just staying
quiet you have two options i can either
do this or i can
file charges if i do i know how the
army's going to react as a first
lieutenant this may be bad for your
career so what do you want to do and the
guy's like you're not giving me any
choice i have to read you both choices
and they eventually walk them to the
back to make sure smoke is doing good
smoke is doing good they stay with them
for 20 to 40 minutes and then eventually
the guy apparently
leaves and he's now asking for a million
bucks the footage comes out but what do
you react when you see someone like this
either one of you guys how do you react
to this you know there there's so much
divisiveness in our country
um blue lives matter black lives matter
social justice getting woke diversify
this that you know i'm a cop i support
the troops there's so much of that
and at the end of the day
and this highlights it all it's like are
you on the side of our troops
or are you on the side of the cops well
they're they're fighting against each
other's instances so which one is it
i think really what it comes down to is
right and wrong
and i think anyone watching this
knows that the cops were wrong in that
situation and i'm sure there's going to
be people there saying
no the cop was right and the guy but
from from a layman's perspective
just from a human perspective
the cops are like
they can escalate a situation or they
can de-escalate a situation yep i don't
know what they're taught and this is i
try to have zero interaction with the
cops for that matt like i v rarely
interact with cops when i do it's do you
like cops or do you not like cops
traditionally i would have said i don't
like cops okay i'm just being honest
because every time i've been
dealt with a cop it's been a situation
like that pulled over in a car
i've had guns drawn on me before driving
through miami they thought i was a drug
dealer whatever like i've had bad
incidents with cops
a cop never i never see him at a shop
that's like hey how's your day going
good yeah so i bought this that's my
perspective
but i understand that they're 99 of cops
are good cops i get that that's a bad
perspective to have i get it but you can
escalate a situation or you can
de-escalate a situation like we talked
about earlier in the show
about do people want to be told what to
do or they want to choose what to do so
when you have a cop yelling a thousand
times get on the ground get on the
ground do what you're told obey your
orders and the guy's like look man
i'mma you can see what i'm wearing here
i'm a lieutenant in the army can we just
have a conversation and the cop has zero
reasonable qualities get out get out get
it like
what is that i'm asking a question like
what is that why can't he say hey look
man we pulled you over because of this
here's what we need you to do we
understand that you're a lieutenant or
sergeant we'd like you to comply but
they're just freaking out on this guy
spraying pepper spray in his face it's
disgusting the guy's gonna likely win
the lawsuit
tom
the most dangerous thing that the police
do factually and statistically is walk
up to a car they pulled over that is the
most dangerous thing that they do and at
night it's even more dangerous however
cops can't be on
ego drive and ego trips about who they
are and what they do in this case
they followed the guy he did not pull
over immediately he was concerned so he
goes to a well-lit gas station and is
cooperating with a quiet voice with his
hands outside in full visibility in this
case the most dangerous thing they do is
walk up to a vehicle
the police have an obligation to do
their job properly and they didn't they
could just walk up and they could have
de-escalated this the police could have
de-escalated it and now
with a reasonable guy being reasonable
keeping his hands there we can see him
any other occupants no sir there's not
my dog's in the back then they pepper
spray him from six feet away when they
can see him in a compliant pose
these cops
escalated it when they were concerned
when they pulled them over they didn't
know what they had and he apparently
didn't pull over for a mile so they
didn't know what they had but they said
they wanted to get to a well-lit area
but they that's right it's up very well
that was actually safer for the cops
and so the cops even if they're nervous
about it hey this guy's not pulling over
at first what are we gonna do oh my gosh
what are we gonna do okay fine but once
you're there you as a police officer if
you're gonna be a cop and you're gonna
continue to be a cop you have to play
both sides you have to calm yourself
down even as you're getting yourself
amped up to protect yourself and your uh
partner but you have to then de-escalate
you have to do it properly all the time
they didn't and i think it's disgusting
that they pepper sprayed the guy from
six feet while being completely
compliant and showing his hands so that
part of it is
way out of line so here's what i think
here's what i think years ago nine years
ago a year ago we brought in mark lamb i
don't know if you remember mark lam not
even a year ago maybe like 10 months ago
jericho sheriff mark
he would call into the show and we
brought him on and i interviewed him
right after when they talked about the
defunding of the police right here we
need to defund the police so i brought
him in
and i interviewed him and i cannot tell
you how many how much hate letters i got
email how dare you put a guy like this
on at a time like this america going
through this and
you you you would you would highlight a
cop like him and even we heard from one
of his
friends from the past okay we're like
listen we don't want to participate in
this calling us giving recording we
don't want anything like this we just
did an interview is what we did here
right
so
the same people that got upset at
officer lamb the opposing party is like
well listen we're so glad you brought
them on because it's about defunding the
police nobody we shouldn't defund the
police
this i highlight here and people come
back will say why would you show
something like this that's so divisive
this is how i believe media needs to be
you need to give both sides on what's
going on and call out when somebody
fully screws up let me explain to what
happened this situation here
um
i don't know what it is to be black
you don't know what it is to be from
iran looking like me okay i don't know
what it is to be white i don't know what
it is to be norway i don't know what it
is to be from venezuela from colombia
from mexico from else i don't know what
it is all i know how to be
is to be middle eastern half armenian
half assyrian from iran who looks like
this with this nose with this ear i
don't look like the average human i look
like i'm a middle eastern this is all i
know what to look like
have i gotten people that have uh uh
what do you call it stereotypes you know
racial what a prejudice yeah of course
you know was it a lot of jokes in the
military hey did you go to school on a
donkey you know are you like a camel
jockey i'm like dude i've never seen a
camel in my life but i get it you know
you're saying whatever you're saying
fine i get it have i heard all those
things i have are you fresh off the boat
i'm a pretty good swimmer by the way so
yeah i don't know if i'm fresh off the
boat but i'm a good damn swimmer right
i don't know what it is to be black i
have no idea what it is to be blocked i
don't
i don't know what it is to have cops
pulling you over at a time like this in
december by the way this is not right
now where things are commerce this is
december
right after election when all the
protesting's still going on you got
capital all this stuff and this guy's
getting pulled over he's sitting there
thinking i'm about to go his grandma was
a former nypd for 30 years by the way if
you listen to the whole story yeah this
guy right here he loves america this is
a pro america guy that loves america
he's just saying dude i do not want to
get pulled over in a dark place let me
go to a gas station yeah you go to a gas
station the guy pulls over you you do
what you do to them i mean
then let's talk about the cops let's
look at the cops what are the cops
worried about so the cops worried about
what what do you what if you know it's
extremely sensitive what the hell are
you doing overreacting remember one time
i got pulled over by a cop and plano i
said i've never been pulled over by a
nice cop like this before and it was
uncomfortable do you remember when i
talked about on a podcast too nice he
was being too nice i'm like why are you
being so nice he says you don't know the
climate right now being a cop i have to
overly be nice he says may i please get
the license sir thank you so much for
cooperating i'm like this sounds like
customer service at like a place that
makes no sense nordstrom's is now
training cops yeah yeah neiman marcus
type of customer service it made no
sense to me the cop that he handled me
and playing i'm like dude i was still
speeding that was reckless driving i
went over the side of the road all
everything you're saying i did so why
are you being so nice i was being a
little reckless the way i drove i was so
he's like here's a ticket it was a
pretty good sized ticket points all this
other stuff i have to deal with that
okay great no problem i deserved
the fine that i got but i was concerned
why the cop was so
scared so that's far
one side this is far the complete
opposite side now let's talk about a
different part about this um had a
friend of mine years ago i'm not going
to say his name i had a friend of mine
years ago we were very close to the
point we're partied every weekend
together we were close together very
very close i'm talking 20 years ago
this guy was the biggest sweetheart adam
i know biggest sweetheart i know
i'm when i say sweetheart i'm talking
sweetheart and guess what he did for a
living he was a nurse
guess what he ends up becoming
after being a nurse he becomes let me
guess a cop a cop okay when i tell you
the biggest sweetheart i'm not telling
you it was the biggest sweetheart
because it just sounds good maybe one of
the top five biggest sweethearts i know
in my life was this guy then he becomes
a cop
then he gets the badge then he gets the
gun
then i go out to lunch with them six
months later a little different the way
he talked to the customer the way he
talked to the waitress six months later
little different the way he talked to
people
two years later a little different three
years later little different
four years later temper flaring
regularly huh
what the hell is going on to this guy
this is not the guy was friends with
five years later a little worse then
eventually gets fired okay from the
police force from the police force wow
and that rarely happens there was some
controversy there but anyways
i will tell you that badge and the gun
that gives you that kind of power
reveals a lot of deep dark sides of a
human being that's not ready to be a cop
they're just not
so on one end it comes up from the guy
that's running it the chief on how they
shape the mindset of a cop if the chief
says
we are the badge we have the gun they
better listen to you or else you drop
their asses these mother okay if you're
teaching me like that dude you're firing
me i'm like oh my gosh but if you're
saying hey these are citizens we work
for the city the taxpayers are paying
for us we got to make sure we respect
everybody everyone's innocent until
proven guilty you've got to be a little
bit paranoid you've got to be careful
and it may not be easy but that's what
we got to do that's what we got to do
yeah i'm going to newport beach one time
i'm going to newport beach with a
business spinning guy what's happening
i'm speaking on this yet i'm 21 years
old 22 years old i got seven people in
my car we're all we're all suited up
we're young we're 21 22 years old
we're driving down to newport i bet
couple of the friends are gonna remember
this event if they're listening to the
podcast right now we're driving down to
newport guy pulls me over
he comes to the side with gun point out
the cars like this i'm like
he comes
put your hand on her steering wheel i'm
like what the hell and i'm not in a
place to talk to me like that at 21
years old i was not reasonable i was
getting out of the military i just got
out of military i'm like dude i am on
fire like i am on fire at this time
right so i put my hands on the stairs i
said what the hell are you doing
so what the hell are you doing are you
rookie how long have you been a cop tell
me you look like you're a rookie cop how
long you been a cop are you a rookie cop
you're a rookie cop ain't you so him and
i start going at it and my guy's like
pat calm down calm down come down
they're right i was overreacting but i
was pissed off you rookie cop you're
rookie cop why are you pulling me over
you won 70. i'm like it's 65.
he said well you're going five minute
five miles over speed i see you cannot
tell me you give me a speeding ticket at
70. going 65 on a 405. i am i said
there's a bunch of people going faster
than me you said well it's like fishing
sometimes when you fish you don't catch
all the fish you're the fish i caught
today i'm like this mother i said okay
give me the ticket i want to show to
court so i want to say what the hell are
you going to do about it so i go to
court
and he's there and i'm asking everybody
officer do you know who that is i do how
long he's been a cop he's a newer cop
oh he's a newer cop yeah anyways the
judge gives me all the stuff that i told
you were rookie cop you gave a ticket at
70 going 70 years old 70 miles out of 65
and you come up with a gun with six
people sitting in the back with all
suited up what the hell are you doing
this is exactly why cops get a bad rep
sometimes now gosh somebody comes into
our house a few months ago cops show up
three of them okay everyone's concerned
cops show up sir is everything okay you
guys comfortable do you need to stay
here ma'am is there anything you want us
to do you want us to walk through every
room please i will do that matter of
fact how about i do that so you're
comfortable melvin are you okay they
wanna walk
anything else you need here's our number
give us a call we're here to help you
the most ridiculous experience eighty
percent of my experiences with cops have
always been good
twenty percent of them have been bad of
the twenty percent that have been bad
probably eighty 80 of it was because i
was being bad so that was at a different
phase of my life where i was acting like
a fool so you understand how to math one
right there 80 20 20 80 of it was my
fault so 20 of it wasn't my fault it's a
very slim margin but when you do things
like this and it goes on camera you
officially hurt other cops that get the
reputation and a
media station shows this to the world
and they don't they don't tell the story
the right way they spin it as all the
cops are like this and then everyone
reacts then there's division then we
have what we have today in america go
ahead are you noticing us
a similarity in your stories in my
stories and the stories that we're
showing
where are all these bad incidents
happening
on the freaking road in a car
cops show up to your house yeah okay
because you call a burglary or whatever
they're like that
a rarely happens and they're there to
defuse what happened what's going on for
whatever reason
the the like you said most um incidents
happen in the car statistically the most
dangerous thing that cop does is come to
the window of your car we're keying in
on what the fear is from cops
and from drivers and like you said we've
i've never been black you know in black
this guy is scared to get out of his car
and he's a freaking lieutenant in the
army first lieutenant okay
imagine if you're just a normal guy in
atlanta or illinois or california and
you're just on the road and you're going
70 in a in a 65 the cop pulls you over
draws the gun and you've seen a million
of these freaking stories
how are you supposed to react you know
the black people you know they have the
talk yeah you always hear i have to have
to talk with my kids i have to have to
talk to my kids you're talking about
that last night
all right look you're going to grow up
and you're going to meet a girl and the
birds and the bees the talk these days
if you're in a black household is you're
going to get mother freaking pulled over
and this is how you need to speak to
like there's this is a thing now this is
reality so you can't dismiss how people
feel and if a lieutenant is scared to
get out of the car
serving america imagine just putting
yourself in the shoes of just a normal
black person in america how they would
feel okay you have
you've had a bad incident with a cop in
a car i've had a ton of them to the
point where i can't even drive a car
this year so a person's saying right now
the guy clearly didn't follow the
instructions and he should have opened
the door see the challenge that's the
first thing i said but if you watch the
whole 31 minute clip which i highly
recommend i don't know what channel it
is let's give a shout out to matt if i
put it below so people can watch it
afterwards just watch the whole 31
minute clip to see what happens
there the reason why he didn't
automatically open the door is because
when you open the door the gun is here
so imagine if he opens the door and they
see the gun they react the guy knows
there's going to be a reaction so there
was a gun in there all his gear was in
the back he was moving because he was
getting orders to go to a different
place so you kind of have to see the
whole story that's a legally owned
weapon it is it is but still you open it
you see a reaction and somebody shoots
you're panicking at that moment nobody
knows what it's like to have only a few
people in the world have been held gun
you know
you don't know how to react when that's
taking place it's a very weird reaction
and people react in a different way all
of us can say whatever he should have
done this but there's a little bit more
to the story look i'm i'm a guy that
defends cops ninety percent of the time
i'm i
i love great cops i sleep better at
night because of great cops i travel
better because of great cops i have put
great events together because of great
cops great cops have taken care of me
and my family my entire life i'm a
byproduct of great cops
cops like this need to get trained
better you need to get you know the same
way i say uh the teachers terrible
teachers need to be fired yeah terrible
cops need to be fired asap
terrible cops who cannot handle like you
know how you do pressure
type of training i'm watching a video
this morning of the guy who's the guy
that uh
he came up with the uh uh the torturing
thing
what's his expertise
james mitchell is the guy that came up
with cia's method to
waterboard enhanced interrogation this
guy very interesting story he's got
there right
so the interviewer says before i
interview you i wanted to be
waterboarded so he goes and gets
waterboarded okay just to kind of get a
feel by the way i wouldn't mind doing
that just to know what it feels like
wow so he gets waterboarded that's an
episode right there then he does the
interview okay then he says
it's terrible being waterboarded right
he's explaining to him what it's like to
be waterboarded so dude the reaction to
this was absolutely insane okay so what
should we do should we get rid of the
bad guys should we keep these bad guys
should we do this
i think cops who are doing things like
this they should get fired i think bad
teachers should be fired i think we need
to just clean house
if you cannot handle
being rattled in a high pressure type
situation you are not qualified to be a
cop and that's not your job that's not
simply your job you need to go do
something else but definitely not be a
cop anyways i may be wrong but that's
how i feel about your analogy by the way
just because i know we're gonna move on
yeah if you have a teacher that's like
open your books read your books
it's like
just tell me what chapter and there are
plenty like that you see the videos on
youtube that go viral like another
example you told vanessa to turn up my
volume 5
you said hey vanessa would you do me a
favor and
vanessa turn up the volume five percent
it's like yeah who acts like that yeah
so
anyways look that's the segment we
covered that with uh
and by the way there are a lot more to
go into with that yes stories we're at
3178 we're 322 away from taking a shout
out to kalella if you don't want us to
take a shot at where you're going to do
it but we may do the next one the next
one i'm not taking a shot
until this gets to 3 500 so we will hang
tight maybe we'll do it on our next
podcast we got 21 minutes left if you
want to share the podcast hit the thumbs
up button so we can taste this thing
together and see what it's like okay
stories what do you want to go to next
uh how do do we go to the wink of our
story do we go to the coin let's talk
about the coin base what the ceo said
yesterday go to page three
i love what the ceo of coinbase said
yesterday he was being transparent when
he was asked on this interview okay
coinbase ceo says regulation is one of
the biggest threats to crypto this is a
cnbc interview here that once again
coinbase ceo brian armstrong
said regulation has won the biggest risk
when it comes down to cryptocurrency
business we're very excited and happy
play uh to play by the rules basically
we just ask that hey we want to be
treated on those level playing field
with traditional financial services at
the very bes at least and not have any
kind of punishment for being in the
crypto space his company is the first
major crypto business to trade publicly
in the u.s coinbase is profitable taking
in 300 322 million dollars last year
an estimated 800 million dollars in
first quarter revenue alone so even the
guy asked a question saying are you
worried about regulation it says
regulation is one of the biggest risks
when it comes down to cryptocurrency
business thoughts well he said the two
biggest risks were cyber security cyber
security yeah that's right he did say
that and shout out to everyone who's
been eager to invest in the ipo for
coinbase and something tells me there
might be a
uh case study case study coming in but
you know
when i kind of first got into the
insurance industry well i've been in it
for a few years everyone was like the
dol the dol and the regulation and the
regulation and for my industry
regulation turned out to be a good thing
uh for the life settlement industry
because when i entered it in 2006 it was
the freaking wild west
so
i guess my question back to you because
you have very strong opinions on this is
is regulation a good thing is it a bad
thing is it somewhere in the middle
where do you think the regulation will
lead
you know who's going to be
um
running the show when it comes to
regulation i'm sort of just giving i
want to get your response on this who
gives the regulation yeah like just give
give the run down the pros and cons
powell exactly well obviously the
chairman fed the secretary treasurer sec
anybody that'll worry about the tax
implications the irs we could do that as
well remember internet we used to have
now no taxes on the internet
internet tax is a new thing when you
used to sell stuff on the internet you
did not pay taxes i don't know if you
knew that or not i might not know that
years ago if you sold stuff on the
internet you didn't pay taxes
until they came out with taxes on the
internet one year it's probably a decade
ago when they came out with taxes on the
internet so what are the pros and cons
can you pay attention please go ahead
keep going what are the pros and cons of
regulation of
tom what are the pros and cons of
regulation the pros and cons of
regulation on uh coinbase well it's the
underlying
crypto crypto okay well
coinbase is just is a market it's a
marketplace yes but if that which it is
marketing the uh individual
cryptocurrencies there's an issue with
them then it has no business and so the
regulation of those things is what he's
worried about he's not worried about
himself being regulated as much as hey
i'm a marketplace i'm a buyer and a
seller and there's rules for that and
you know people have to you know to have
accounts everything protection of
privacy regulation for that but now
regularly dependent of what correct
correct he's basically running like a
robin hood for
that's what i called it last year
exactly
the pros of regulation on cryptocurrency
is that it is a new medium and i believe
that there's a lot we don't understand
and need to do number one and number two
we're also we're actually trusting the
technology sector that the privacy and
any of the things that can happen
underneath it are working
and so i i think there needs to be you
know regulation underneath on all of the
people so don't worry about it it's on
the blockchain that's
well we don't know how
do we know do we have a
do does the fbi have a division that
completely understands all the ways that
maybe you can manipulate the blockchain
and cheat honest people probably not
probably not yet concerned so do we need
regulation and laws to make sure there's
guardrails and everything on there to
protect people that are investing in it
absolutely that's the pros of regulation
the cons of regulation is this is
politicized and the fiat currencies are
threatened and so inside oh we need to
regulate it for the safety and the you
know the integrity of the system and to
protect the individual investor there's
also political things out there there's
a lot of people that don't particularly
you know want this to be competing with
currency bases so you know i know you
know you know what's got to be
frustrating is to the billionaires who
became billionaires through business and
the stock market who don't believe in
crypto
they got to be very upset right now
because a lot of those guys are getting
threats from guys who are skaters who
are about to be billionaires and they're
like dude you're not a qualified
billionaire and they're about to become
billionaires
many of these guys are about to become
billionaires yeah and and the
billionaires who went to the right
schools they have the right last names
they did it all the right way and they
got picked up and they made all them
nothing wrong with them more power to
them i salute a lot of these
entrepreneurs
but it's got to be tough for some of
these guys to say they were so
anti-crypto i've never been anti-crypto
i've been
it's regulation is eventually going to
get you because i know how politicians
work when you become too powerful you
know it's really interesting you say
that but i see history repeating itself
here and i know crypto's got a lot of
regulation there's a lot more to it and
it's competing with currency systems yes
but there were media barons that were
saying the same thing about jerry yang
at yahoo and about steve case at aol
oh these guys have just gone through
zero to six true and now they're media
guys
oh gosh they didn't do it the way we did
it we built this thing up channel by
channel walter cronkite and all this
stuff and these guys come out of nowhere
in their billionaires absolutely
same thing is happening today yeah it's
tough
it's tough when you get a newer wave
that's coming in that's like right now
how many people are right now saying
steph curry is the most exciting player
in the league a lot a lot they're saying
he's the modern-day michael jordan head
of lebron james that's what's trending
today he's the most exciting player
they're not saying he's the greatest
they're saying he is the most exciting
player in the league right now like
michael jordan
how come they're not saying lebron
because lebron is not as exciting steph
curry why lebron's big 6-8 jumps 41
inches he can dunk he's like a
linebacker 285 pounds
steph curry is bitcoin
because steph cruz the way of winning is
shooting eleven threes yesterday in 29
minutes scoring 43 points in the night
before scores 50 points makes 10 degrees
passes will chamberlain but he doesn't
dunk the ball no it's a very different
game and attention's going in a
different direction with crypto and some
of these guys that have forever been the
main guys going on cnbc msnbc all these
play they're like a little bit less
being called upon than the other guys
are so make a prediction because you've
been talking about regulation regulation
regulation for bitcoin and crypto for a
while now where do you see this going
i think if uh if you study history
politicians
eventually figured out a way to create
laws to impose themselves on
those who are entrepreneurs and
different thinkers that's correct they
eventually figure out ways to create
laws against them and guess what
entrepreneurs typically find a way to do
entrepreneurs and innovators typically
find a way to go around them yeah of
course and this happens this is a battle
that's going to happen over and over and
over and over and over again and guess
what majority people hate in the world
do majority of people love billionaires
and millionaires or do majority people
hate them more on the latter more on the
ladder so what what do they vote for do
they vote for leave them alone and let
them keep creating or do they vote for
hey do whatever you can to create more
restrictions for them
and that is that is sort of the
fickleness of the average the fickleness
of the of the mob goes like this they
cheer for you as the underdog but if you
win the game and host the trophy now
they don't like you
the guy says give pb give kd some love
it's tough to give nets some love man
i'll start going in what i was looking
at i'm sorry case study i know you got a
coinbase case study coming up but we
have a coinbase case study that we did
two years ago so go back and check on
that we're going to do a follow-up on
valuetainment by the way kai told me
yesterday i showed the text to you kai
told me yesterday your disney case
studies the best one he's ever seen and
i came out yesterday we watched a ducati
case study last week on the drive to
miami thank you very much i appreciate
that where do you see if regulation does
come in where do you how does that
affect the price of bitcoin specifically
that's a great question it depends what
kind of regulation they impose
but to be honest with you i don't think
by a lot
i don't think by a lot i don't think
regulation will affect i think crypto's
going i think crypto's going i think
crypto's going to go and do what it's
going to do but regulation is going to
come some parts of the sector of crypto
is going to take a hit i don't know
which one it is right because you have
to think about
how will they regulate
how from what angle will they take it to
be a pain in the butt for the crypto
community what angle will they take
what angle will it be no one knows
well and you know it all comes back
around again i mean that the banking
banking is here to make money loaning
money right the core of banking makes
money doing that nicola just commented
right now i gave five bucks saying
regulations are coming ripple is on a
lawsuit right now with sec right now
this will be good for the entire space
keep an eye on it there you go yep go
back to 2008 right
what was the problem in real estate
qualification standards were too low
right nina no income no problem right
and um
now you have real estate prices are even
higher than what they were and the
interest rate is a problem but no one's
talking about there's also the
adjustable interest rate sitting at two
and a quarter to start
what does it take to double that five
that's not a big jump for interest rates
but that would basically
double those mortgage payments and yet
they were saying oh we've cleaned the
whole thing up the qualifications are
different everything no
you know people are being qualified
still on the front end the argument on
adjustables is they're qualifying people
on the front end the payment on the
front end not the payment for the
potential and so you're you're you
follow that you let the back end ratios
be way too heavy on the adjustable
mortgage on the starting point and you
don't say listen i'm going to qualify
for this based on the starting point
plus a point and a half that's what i'm
going to qualify you remember they were
talking about we're going to do all
these things make it safer so people
can't accidentally get into bad
mortgages wrong the banks want to give
up mortgages they want to loan them out
and we may not be doing nina but we've
had other ways that we are out there
loaning money and as your point is
capitalism finds a way the market finds
a way did you see what peter thiel said
about crypto and what uh he said about
china yeah he said it's an enemy and it
says and they're in bed with russia and
china kind of thing yeah who's in bed
say it again yeah i'm paraphrasing but
peter thiel said continue in that
because i only saw i scanned it i did
not dive in yeah he he was uh he was
saying china is going to use crypto in a
way to
uh uh bring the fiat currency down in
the u.s to manipulate the fiat currency
to bring it down in the u.s they're
going to use crypto to do that go ahead
and remove the dollar as the reserve
currency so actually trying to attack
that yeah
a billion percent believe china would
want to do something like that i mean
that's why why would why would they not
i thought you'd think highly of china so
for no i don't know okay i'm not that's
ccp they don't do it for me no after
that economic forum right there
no okay all right sounds good any store
you want to go with do you really want
to touch up on that elon musk i do and i
also want to also just
we don't spend a lot of time on it
bernie made off with your money has died
do you want to go through that story
over the uh so bernie made i'd like to
do both if we have time let's go is
there any really nine minutes is there
anything really there on bernie i don't
think there's really anything the story
was over and he went to prison and now
he died of kidney failure bernie madoff
wall street financier ponzi scheme died
at 82 years old the financier developed
close relations with major players in
the financial sector sector and used his
network to spark what became the largest
case of financial fraud in u.s history
wealthiest financiers were drawn into
the business seeking a prestige that
demanded with madoff's firm a garnering
of new capital kicked off uh mazeoff's
ponzi scheme new investment would pay
off
those having already joined and new
clients were encouraged to attract more
investors the madoff was uh madoff was
arrested in new york december of 2008
after whistleblower who was later
identified as one of his sons said the
financier was failing to pay seven
billion dollars to his clients you sound
like you have something
so i entered the financial sector in
2006 2007
and this is all they talked about at
that time and and well 2008 happened
bernie was the talk of the town and this
is what's going on and people were
trying to get their money out
and in the middle of the mortgage crisis
in the middle of the mortgage crisis and
and i was in an industry that was
definitely the wild west and there were
some shady players you you met with some
of those guys down in waco texas and my
firm this is a life settlement to be a
clear life settlement exactly life
settlements um
and there were some shady players in
that and and it taught me
that
um
at the end of the day no matter what you
do the truth will come out and at the
end of the day when we're all
you know leave this earth
the only thing you'll have left is your
legacy and what's the legacy that bernie
madoff has like nobody if your last name
is made off you need to change your name
at this point so
let's look at some other people that you
know around that time have had a fall
from grace bernie madoff bill cosby
harvey weinstein all these guys were
making millions and billions in
ridiculous amount but
low-key they were complete scumbags and
at the end of the day the truth will
come out so my challenge to our friends
out there and i assume that 99 of them
are doing good things and reputable
things but to the one percent of you
that are ripping people off with crypto
or doing shadier things the truth will
come out you will get caught and like
madoff it might take you
freaking 40 years but you're gonna die
in jail and it's a sad situation and i
just tell you i'm bad i just tell you
one story you know when you do things
like this my concern is the following so
madoff is not a common name it's not
like it's jones or johnson or you know
whatever it is right madoff is a very
unique last name who takes a hit when a
man like this screws up the rest of his
the kids
his son committed suicide suicide in
2008 you know he left a note on the
table you know what he said here's a
note he left at the end bernie now you
know how you have destroyed the lives of
your sons by your life of deceit f you
mark madoff and then he killed himself
his son that's the tragic part of the
story that breaks my heart with the kids
that's the only that's the main thing
the money stuff we can't get away from
con artists by the way the people that
were involved kevin bacon wasn't it
katzenberg was an investor sandy colfax
not not they were part of it they're
like yeah
yeah yeah they lost money these are
these are smart people that got that
took a hit for this
but the one that concerns me the most is
his son who grew up admiring pops and
then this is
he killed his heartbreak breaking to say
the least heartbreaking to say the least
anyways he's definitely so uh
so so there's the bernie madoff story do
you want to go into the story with uh
your friend or no we've got five minutes
left so six minutes left so let's go
into it so so so let's go into stu story
of elon musk
elon musk's girlfriend grimes shares
topless video of her alien back tattoo
and details very elaborate design
process guy if you want to pull that up
a business insider so adam brought up
the story says i swear to god if we
don't cover this on the podcast i'm
going to lose my mind
okay so the musician 33 real name claire
elise boucher
unveiled her beautiful alien scars
tattoo which covered her entire back it
is a little
wonder grimes was given a nod to
extraterrestrial activity given her
recent voicing of plans to relocate to
mars after she turns 50 to help erect
the human colony and her partner the
world's richest man revealed an
ambitious plan to get humans on mars by
2026 seven years before nasa aims to
land astronauts on the red planet so
what do you think about that like what
reaction did you have today so here's my
reaction and zero percent of my action
actually has to do with grimes herself
because if she wasn't dating or the baby
mama of elon musk it would just be a
weirdo chick that does stuff like this
so kudos to her if she wants to get
tatted up like an alien and be also into
anime and all that stuff good for her
but what this does is gives us some deep
insight into how elon musk thinks
and what he's doing in the bedroom and
what's going on in his mind and
basically here's my opinion on uh our
friend elon musk the guy's worth
a hundred and something billion dollars
200 billion okay so the guy's killing
he's on top of the world arguably him
and bezos the top two entrepreneurs on
the planet
he's had some gorgeous women in his in
his life he used to date amanda heard
who was
um johnny depp johnny depp's ex so he's
had women he's had fun he's had money
this is why he's so obsessed with space
and spacex
and
everything that he's doing with that
because he's done everything on earth
and all he's about at this point is
having sex with aliens and he's turning
his girl into a freaking alien
and they had their son the kid has an
alien name that's a x e g b d whatever
the hell it is elon musk i'm coming out
and saying it i've all
amazing respect for you elon musk
[ __ ] aliens i said it there it is
he's doing it he wants to do it he wants
to travel to space
he's had so much success in his life
he's so at this point that all he can
focus on is otherworldly things like
banging aliens there it is
[Music]
and i'm out did you eat some burritos
this morning show some pictures of them
together let's get it all i gotta say
hang on here get on the ball here stay
here kai stay here
this whole story is bs
because
senebet david drew that to me and handed
me that piece of paper the last time i
was in town so meaning it doesn't even
look like a tattoo no
it's satisfactory and the real question
is how'd they get it i'm more worried
about email security on your server
because your daughter drew that and you
gave it to me she was sorry other
pictures other pictures
no i'm i'm doubling down that elon musk
is looking to get the space to bang more
aliens there i said i don't know but
there's there's just no
okay she's normal in that i mean there's
nothing to it i mean it didn't look like
him
see more pictures pull that one up big
screen on the top right
this guy could have any woman in the
world and he wants to bang an alien
this is what i'm saying you're so funny
could elon musk not arguably not have
any woman in the world let me not have
anyone in my heart can he have any woman
underwear meaning good looking guy
worthy
sure he can do whatever he wants yeah so
why is he why is he you know with an
alien yeah did you ever party with any
friends that were into different kind of
girls then yes and i'm like what the
hell are you doing bro this is what i'm
at this is
i don't want you to just tell us what is
your type so if this is not your type
what's your tattoo tell the world what
you're talking about
conventional beautiful women
conventional
very specific conventional beautiful
more brunette brown eyes i've done the
blonde thing for many years i've never
had sex with an alien i don't plan to
um so you can't even answer the question
without i just said beautiful brunette
brown eyes just conventional so never
once you hooked up with an illegal alien
down in miami i'm sure i have i hope
that was a lot of watch your language a
lot of illegal aliens there's a
venezuelan there's a peruvian there's a
colombian there's great i don't know but
i'm not looking for anyone from
um mars no that's not
a martian
sam sam can you take adam minus a
hundred percent please
let's ask the crowd if that's just her
or not let's ask our audience we got a
minute or so left let's see what's going
on here i see a lot of people that are
agreeing with me this might be the first
time ever that people on the
valuetainment pbd products if you're
wearing listen i mean i see a lot of
power to you i see a lot there's there's
one or two things in my mind i see a lot
of laughter i see adam's right i see a
lot of thumbs up
elon musk could have any girl in the
world he's choosing to bang an alien
okay i saw a comment that says soy boy
mafia goes after paypal mafia oh
there we go fair enough all right hey so
after five five cups
we didn't even show the video of the
bitcoin guy we didn't get a chance do we
have time for that no we do not we got
it we got but we'll maybe show it on
thursday and we'll cut it up even better
so we show we'll release it okay or
tuesday uh today's what today's thursday
today is thursday yeah are we doing
tuesday who do we have anybody on
tuesday or any specific special guest
next week or what do we got next week we
might have a special guest but he's not
going it's not 100 and that special
guest is a big special guest we're
excited about that one that's going to
be eventually but it may be this tuesday
flying out here okay all good well stay
tuned we'll do it again tuesday gang
please subscribe and click the
notification button even if you think
you've already subscribed it's a
different channel so when the podcast
pops up we alert you take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you